ما زاد عن حده انقلب ضده هذا ما يحدث ايضا
عند تناول مسكنات الصداع النصفي بشكل مفرط
التحذير اطلقه وطباع صعب مؤكدين ان
المتاعب ستزيد ويصبح الصداع اكثر ليس هذا
فقط بل ان مثل هذه الادويه التي تحتوي على
مواد افيونيه تعد مشكله بشكل خاص لانها
ترفع خطر ادمانها من قبل المرضى الجمعيه
الالمانيه للطب الاعصاب توصلت لهذه
النتيجه وشددت على ضروره الالتزام بجرعات
ادويه الصداع النصريه المحدده من قبل
الطبيب
عندما يفرط مرضى الصداع نصفي وصداع التوتر
في استخدام ادويتهم يمكن ان يسببوا
لانفسهم المزيد من الصداع هذه الحاله تسمى
صداع الافراط في استخدام الادويه ولم
يتوصل الباحثون للاسباب الدقيقه الا انهم
يعتقدون انها تؤثر على عمل الدوبامين في
الجسم وهو ناقل عصبي يعاني مليارات
الاشخاص في العالم اما من الصداع نصفي او
الصداع الناتج عن التوتر والحل الاسهل
بالنسبه لهم هو استخدام الادويه التي لا
تستلزم وصفه طبيه واذا زاد استخدامها اكثر
من يومين او ثلاثه ايام في الاسبوع فقد
يصل المريض لمرحله الافراط في تناول
الادويه هذا الاضطراب يؤثر على ما يقدر
بنحو 100 مليون بالغ على مستوى العالم في
النهايه فان افضل طريقه لتجنب الصداع
الناتج عن الافراط في تناول الادويه هي
تقليل
الاصابه بالصداع في المقام الاول
[موسيقى]
في استديو ينضم لنا استشاره بالدماء
والاعصاب الدكتور محمد مزعل اهلا بك دكتور
محمد يسعد صباحك نورنا في الاستديو صباح
اهلا وسهلا بكم طيب دكتور دراسه تقول انه
الافراط في تناول مسكنات وادويه الصداع
يجعل الصداع اكثر شده الى طبيا هذا دقيق
هو اعتقد نبدا بتعريف الصداع اوكي يكون
افضل الجمهور الصداع بشكل عام هو الم يصيب
الراس اوكي ما هو الراس الراس هو هذا
فروه الراس والوجه هو اعلى الرقبه اوكي
اكيد طبعا افراز في استخدام المسكنات
الالم يؤدي الى قله فاعليتها
فكلما قلت فاعليه الادويه التي تستخدم لاي
كان من الامراض
وموضوعنا اليوم الصداع سيؤدي بالنتيجه اذا
تفاقم المرض لانها تصبح غير فاعله وتبقى
الادويه كلها في المحصله النهائيه هي مواد
كيميائيه تعمل باسلوب معين يعني معظم
ادويه الصداع او الادويه اللي بتخفف من
الم الصداع الراس هلا ما بدنا نحكي
اسمائها لغرض الدعايه لكن دائما ناخذ
حبتين من هذا الدواء الفلاني هل ممكن انه
احنا نسينا ناخذ مثلا حبه ولا المساله مش
هيك بالتخفيف
هو المصطلح العلمي
يعني الصداع الناتج عن الافراد في استخدام
المسكنات الالم وعليه في هذه الحاله تصبح
مسكنات الالم غير فاعله اوكي نوقفها لحين
ما يعيد الجسد او الجسم استعداد لاستقبال
هذه المواد ونبدا مثل ما تفضلتي يفضل
نعطيها بالضروره القصوى حبه او حبتين مع
بعض حسب نوع الاسم طبعا اللي انت ما تحبين
الاسماء فما راح اذكر اسماء طيب ما الحل
دكتور في حال الشعور المتكرر بالصداع
النصفي او الصداع توتري ونتجنب هذه
الادويه
عموما هو هذا السؤال جميل جدا احنا نبدا
بالتعريف الصداع بشكل عام هو قلنا الم
الراس والراس هو فروه الراس والوجه على
الرقبه الصداع ينقسميه رئيسيه صداع اولي
اللي هم اللي اشرت لهم صداع الشقيقه وصداع
التوتر وذني يمثلون الغالبيه العظمى
والصداع
الناتج عن الامراض معينه هذا الصداع اللي
هو التوتري والصداع الشقيقه في الغالب هو
يصير فئات العمريه الشابه وفي الغالب يكون
مع بعض كلاهما مع بعض انا حبيت اليوم
اتكلم بشكل اوسع اذا تسمحون انتم مثلا عن
موضوع هذا عن موضوع الشقيقه الصداع النصفي
لانه هو اكثر شيوعا في الفئات الشابه من
سنه 12 سنه الى سنه 60 سنه او معظم الفئات
العمريه الان مع العصر الحديث ومع الحداثه
ومع
اعداد وراثي للاسرائيلي
محدد لكن في استقبال اسري يعني يعني
تقريبا اكثر من نصف المرضى من الصداع
النصفي الشقيقه تجد عندهم تاريخ اسري سواء
ام خاله عمه اختها
الحلوه طبعا هو واحد من الاشياء المهمه
والتقسيم طبعا كلش مهم التقسيم حتى نقدر
نعرف انه المريض في اي خانه فعندنا
الابيسودك اللي هو المنفرد الحالات اللي
هي تكون اقل من عشره واقل من 15 حاله
والحالات اللي تكون اكثر من 15
ما فوق اذا كانت نوبات الصداع عده 15 نوبه
فما فوق اللي نسميها الصداع صداع النصفي
المزمن صداع الشقيقه المزمن هنا المعالجه
مختلفه وهنا الموضوع مهم طبعا وهو احب
انوه اله هو انه احنا نستخدم ماده
البوتوكس في صداع النصفي المزمن
به يعني
هذا السبب طبعا معظم الفئات العمريه
الشابه يعني شابات بنات اوكي ومعظم الناس
اللي تشتغل في الشفتات نظام الشيفت يعني
النظام يعني الوجبات اللي هو نهار لنهار
معرضين اكثر الى موضوع الصداع النصفي ففي
حالات اذا كان صداع 15 يوم فما اكثر
نستخدم ماده البوتكس وفعال جدا يقلل
لعازات الالم الذهب الى الدماغ ويدخل
عضلات المحيطه في الراس 70% حسب اللوائح
العالميه والمقالات الطبيه يستجيبون ومن
تجربته في العياده من سنه 2010 ولحد الان
اكثر من 90% من المرضى يستفادون الحل هو
البوتكس لتخفيف الصداع المزمن المزمن شكرا
جزيلا لك